- I've been thinking on this
notion of political courage
this weekend.
In particular about some
of the men and women
who were elected to Congress
the same year I was
elected to the White House.
Many of them were new to Washington.
Their entire careers ahead of them.
And in that very first term,
they had to take tough
vote after tough vote
because we were in crisis.
They took votes to save
the financial system
and the economy even when
it was highly unpopular.
They took votes to save the auto industry,
when even in Michigan people
didn't wanna see bailouts.
They took votes to crack
down on abuses on Wall Street
despite pressure from lobbyists
and sometimes their donors.
And they found themselves in
the midst of a great debate.
A debate that had been
going on for decades.
A debate that the Kennedy family
had participated in and helped lead.
A debate about whether a nation
as wealthy as the United States of America
would finally make health
care not a privilege
but a right for all Americans.
(audience applauding)
And there was a reason
why health care reform
had not been accomplished before.
It was hard.
It involved 1/6 of the economy
and all manner of
stakeholders and interests.
It was easily subject to misinformation
and fearmongering.
And so by the time the vote came up
to pass the Affordable Care Act,
these freshman congressmen
and women knew that
they had to make a choice.
That they had a chance to insure millions
and prevent untold worry,
suffering, and bankruptcy and even death.
But that this same vote would likely
cost them their new seats,
perhaps end their political careers.
These men and women did the right thing.
They did the hard thing.
There's was a profile in courage.
Because of that vote,
20 million people got health insurance
who didn't have it.
And most of them (audience applauding)
and most of them did lose their seats.
They were true to what President Kennedy
defined in his book
as a Congressional profile in courage,
desire to maintain a
reputation for integrity
that is stronger than a
desire to maintain office.